Вони випалюють землю і рухаються за нею, як пожежа, розумієте.
Ти не можеш там стояти, бо ти згориш.
Якщо я потраплю в полон, мене навряд чи залишать живим, тому що я для них занадто яскравий ворог.
Кров убитих дітей Бучі, закатованих чоловіків і зґвалтованих жінок - на руках кожного росіянина.
Поки війна не закінчиться, я до камери не стану і знімати нічого не буду. Тільки після перемоги.
Мене в’язниця не зламала і війна мене не зламає.
Про реалії війни, стан справ на фронті і про кіно ми говоримо з режисером
і колишнім політв'язнем Кремля Олегом Сенцовим.
Він нині захищає Україну у складі ЗСУ.
Олеже, ви зараз на Донбасі. Яка нині ситуація на фронті?
Я перебуваю зараз на найважчій ділянці - це район Сєвєродонецька, від Сєвєродонецька до Бахмута.
Тому що це Луганська область - остання частина, яка не окупована росіянами,
і вони намагаються це зробити, кидають усі зусилля, тому що їм потрібно показувати хоч якусь перемогу,
в даному плані показувати Луганську область, яку, як вони кажуть, вони "звільнили".
У вчорашньому відео на фейсбуці ви розповідали, що на передній край відправляють хлопців з тероборони,
які не дуже підготовлені до такого бою. Наскільки таких людей багато?
По-перше, крім тероборони, крім мобілізованих, які теж мало підготовлені, таких людей багато.
Але треба воювати, а як же. Це не якась претензія або звинувачення.
Це проблема, яка існує, яку треба вирішувати швидко, тобто робити кращу підготовку в тилах, або тут на другій лінії, або далі.
Тобто людей вистачає, люди самі рвуться в бій, люди дуже вмотивовані, але треба просто навчитися це робити.
Тому що вони роблять помилки, які призводять до травм.
На війні я вже два місяці і я жодного разу не зробив жодного пострілу.
Велика відстань між ворогуючими сторонами, і стрілковий бій буває дуже рідко.
Переважно боротьба з артилерії, з мінометів і РСЗО, а піхота тільки тримає рубежі.
І важливо вижити в цих умовах, а не загинути, не бути пораненим, не бути обузою.
Тобто навички виживання дуже важливі на фронті. Краще, ніж вміння вбивати насправді.
А те що воює ТРО - воюють усі, розумієте.
Тобто ТРО-шників дуже багато воює і нема різниці насправді між ТРО і між мобілізованими ЗСУ.
Просто людина приходить, записується в підрозділ, їй дають автомат і вона йде воювати.
Те, що в документах написано, не має жодного стосунку до її кваліфікації.
Так само і ви пішли. Ви приєдналися в перші дні війни до ТРО.
Що для вас стало головною мотивацією, головним поштовхом?
Там давали автомат. Там одразу давали автомат - усе.
Із мобілізацією це було б довго, і не мобілізували на той час із мого району у військову частину,
тобто я подзвонив у воєнкомат і мені сказали: “Тільки рота охорони, яка охороняє сам воєнкомат”.
Я пішов у ТРО в той самий день, тому що там роздавали зброю.
Ситуація була така, що вже було розуміння, що зараз буде вторгнення в сам Київ, зараз почнуться вуличні бої в самому Києві.
Треба було мати зброю, підрозділ, якусь мінімальну злагодженість, бути не просто м’ясом, яке бігає по вулицям.
А будь-який підрозділ може вести бій.
Я дуже багато чого навчився за ці два місяці, дійсно.
І зараз маю зовсім інший рівень підготовки, ніж був до цього.
Я і до цього багато чого знав, але тут мене це цікавить, і це важливо, якщо ти хочеш воювати,
ти повинен уміти це робити. На війні дуже важливо мати якісь додаткові навички,
додаткову військову професію, а не просто - “я вмію стріляти з автомата”. Це дуже мало, треба вміти ще.
Це вже війна зовсім інша, воює зброя розумна, і тому важливо отримати таку зброю.
Тому що у нас її мало, вона застаріла.
У Росії вона трохи нова, але її дуже багато, і тут на Донбасі вони показують, що у них дуже багато боєприпасів.
Тобто вогневе ураження, вогневий шторм, який вони роблять з усіх видів зброї, це дуже серйозна штука.
І вони просто витискають нас, ми змушені відходити, а вони потроху займають ці позиції.
Вони випалюють землю і рухаються за нею, як пожежа, розумієте. Ти не можеш там стояти, бо ти згориш.
Ти змушений відступати, поступово, з втратами, а вони просуваються. Ось така зараз у них стратегія.
Так у них було в Сирії, в Чечні.
Просто в перші дні вони думали, що можна колонами так вільно зайняти Україну,
у них не вийшло, тому вони повертаються до старої стратегії випаленої землі.
Тобто картинка трохи дійсно відрізняється від того, що ми бачимо в новинах? Дійсно мало бачимо?
Певний момент, акцент такий на позитивних новинах, скажімо так, і на наших успіхах,
на знеціненні ворога, що він такий слабкий, такий дурний - це не дуже правильно.
Люди перестають розуміти реальність. І ті, хто на фронт приїжджають, і ті, хто в тилу.
Очікують швидких перемог. Думають, що війна повинна бути легкою і вже влітку ми маємо захопити Крим.
І якщо з бойовим навчанням, злагодженням ми ще розберемося, я сподіваюся, в найближчі часи,
то важке озброєння ми не зможемо зробити самі, у нас його майже нема.
Тобто це дуже залежить від наших західних партнерів, від того, як будуть постачати зброю.
У цьому плані дуже показова позиція Німеччини, яка побачивши реальне обличчя Росія, зрозуміла,
що Росія і Путін - це сучасний фашизм і з ним треба боротися, змінила свою позицію і почала надавати зброю.
Інакше, без такої допомоги, без лендлізу широкого, не лише американського, а і європейського ми не переможемо.
За вашими відчуттями, скільки ще може тривати ця війна?
Важко сказати. Постійно такі питання, особливо з тилу вони доносяться.
Прогнози робити важко, я думаю, два-три роки - до цього треба готуватися.
Раніше це навряд чи відбудеться, тому що щоб нам треба не тільки перемогти тут,
зупинити Росію, звільнити територію, нам треба робити тиск на Росію, добитися зміни режиму,
тому що інакше це буде проблема. Якщо там просто буде державний переворот і змінять Путіна на Патрушева або Шойгу,
ситуація не зміниться, Росія залишиться проблемою.
Ви п’ять років були в російському полоні, в ув’язненні.
Чи не боїтеся ви зараз, що ця історія може повторитися,
що ви потрапите в полон і станете такою собі фішкою для російської пропаганди?
Ну по-перше, не може так нещастити двічі, це буде вже занадто.
Я думаю, що своє в полоні я вже відсидів, думаю, що на мене чекають інші випробування, що не буде повторення.
А по-друге, якщо я потраплю в полон, мене навряд чи залишать живим, тому що я для них занадто яскравий ворог.
І я думаю, що це закінчиться швидкою стратою.
Або не швидкою, а не дуже приємною, такий можливий варіант.
Це життя, тут багато хлопців, які віддають своє життя просто зараз,
і я не можу не бути поруч із ними, для мене це неможливо.
На вашу думку, що може чекати на захисників “Азовсталі”, які потрапили в полон фактично?
Потрібно розуміти трохи російський наратив.
Для них є меседж “нацисти, фашисти”, яким вони виправдовують свою війну постійно, вони вказують на це.
І зараз вони будуть намагатися робити з них такий гучний процес, показати свою перемогу, виправдати своє вторгнення.
Тому я би не розраховував на швидкий обмін.
Можливо, когось вони ідентифікують як поліцію, або як ЗСУ, або як морську піхоту, то їх вони можуть віддати раніше.
А тих, хто з полку “Азов”, з них будуть робити показний процес, тому що Росії треба щось робити для внутрішньої пропаганди.
У них немає великих перемог, тому все, що вони можуть сказати - “ось, ми перемогли нацистів у Маріуполі”.
Головне, щоб вони були живі, щоб їх не стратили, не катували - це дуже важливий момент.
Я розумію, що цього не відбувається, бо є певні домовленості, Червоний хрест моніторить,
і дали можливість Редису (це командир “Азова”) навіть поговорити з дружиною.
Якби були якісь проблеми, він сказав хоча б два слова про те, що відбувається.
Тобто я думаю, що все більш менш нормально, але, можливо, ув’язнення до кінця війни.
Я не вірю, що Путін їх поміняє.
Ще питання з культурної сфери. Цього тижня був скандал на Каннському кінофестивалі
із російським режисером Кирилом Серебренніковим, якого раніше вважали російським дисидентом.
Але він виступив на захист російських солдат і проти “кенселінгу” російської культури.
Що ви скажете на це, яка ваша позиція з приводу цього?
Треба розуміти нам таку річ, що Серебренніков - це російський режисер, не український,
він дивиться зі своєї точки зору і все.
Це не прямий ворог, але і не прямий друг, треба не звертати на це уваги, як на мене.
А стосовно кенселінгу Росії - це не стосовно тільки кенселінгу культури, це кенсел Росії.
Тому що Росія відповідає за всі злочини.
Кров убитих дітей Бучі, закатованих чоловіків і зґвалтованих жінок - на руках кожного росіянина.
Тих, хто це зробив, тих, хто їх туди послав, тих, хто це підтримує, і тих, хто промовчав,
і того Кирила Серебреннікова, який каже, що треба допомагати російським солдатам.
Для мене кров невинних жертв на їхніх руках.
Їм ніколи не відмитися від цього. І що б вони там не казали - для мене це вже закрите питання.
Чи змінила вас війна?
Мене не змінила війна, я просто отримав додаткові навички і продовжую їх отримувати.
Це не зміна особистості, це не зміна… Я ж уже доросла людина, мені не 18 років, щоб у мене зламалася психіка.
У мене ж уже було багато чого в житті, зокрема й важкого.
Мене в’язниця не зламала і війна мене не зламає.
Просто я якось розвиваюся в певних навичках і в певному закалюванні.
Чи вплинула війна на ваші творчі плани?
Творчі плани не змінилися. Тобто є сценарій, який написаний, і який я збираюся знімати.
І от мій партнер Денис Іванов поїхав у Канни, зараз працює над пошуком партнерських грошей
для соціальної драми “Кай” української, і для нашого проєкту англійською мовою - Shining World, “Сяючий світ”.
Це така дитяча історія для дорослих. Це історія, яку я написав у карцері в російській в’язниці.
Крім того у мене з’явилися певні ідеї про війну, вже з’явилися.
Коли у мене з’являється ідея, я певний час думаю, вона живе зі мною,
а потім через кілька місяців або навіть років вона виливається у вигляді сценарію.
Я б із задоволенням насправді - у мене є хороша ідея зняти про “Азовсталь” велике кіно, але зараз не на часі, по-перше.
Поки війна не закінчиться, я до камери не стану і знімати нічого не буду. Тільки після перемоги.
Це однозначне моє рішення. Але до цього у мене не було бажання знімати кіно про війну, а зараз воно з’явилося.
Але це бажання поки у вигляді сценаріїв, а реалізація уже після перемоги.
Дуже сподіваюся, що вдасться усе це реалізувати, при чому якомога швидше.
Дякую за інтерв’ю, за те, що поділилися своїми переживаннями, і головне - бережіть себе.
Дякую, дякую, на все добре.